i'm really surprised how this all went
down if i'm being honest i mean you know
you're very outspoken about it um
you have such a strong opinion about the
other way i thought that you would
indulge it was crazy that i'm looking
out for my friend
and i'm telling you it's not a good idea
do you believe in your heart of hearts
do you believe there is a chance if i
did this that i could get in some form
of trouble
i'm not asking you
hey you little
i'm talking to you directly
i'm coming on tour and i don't always do
it so you got to come see me and here we
go april 15th and 16th i will be in
louisville and evansville april 23rd and
24th i will be in tulsa and oklahoma
city beacon theater new york city first
time may 14th there's going to be some
surprise guests there and that's all i
could say but you do not want to miss
that and i'm going out west cali i'm
finally coming to you i'm going to be in
san diego on may 21st and at the wilton
theater in los angeles for the first
time ever on may 22nd everything is
available right now at
savilicanocomedy.com you little
april 8th the egyptian room at the old
national center in indianapolis indiana
april 9th denver colorado april 16th
wall street theater norwalk connecticut
april 29th wind creek event center in
pennsylvania christy comedy.com for all
the tiki wikis thank you guys we'll see
you at the
don't be a show don't run away from your
feelings babe don't be afraid don't be
ashamed don't hesitate to say hey babe
hey babe hey baby
i mean we come in with a little energy
if you're gonna do it if not don't do it
and we'll make it
[Applause]
start over ready i don't need you to
worry for me cause i'm all
i don't care what you say anymore this
is
go ahead with your own life leave me
alone
hey babe how you doing babe hey babe oh
you fell right into it that i wasn't
gonna get into this no surprise
babe surprise surprise surprise christos
stefano has a severe case of covet
[Music]
[Laughter]
i know the pig has swine flu
and he couldn't be here
no uh we don't know the last minute
chris is not just generally not feeling
well uh we thought it was best him to
rest up as we're all burning the uh the
candle at both ends and uh in for the
substitute the hot tagging as we say in
wrestling is everyone's favorite joe
derose
yeah from the no pressure family no
pressure network well you're the one i
mean well you and chris are adversaries
yes
yes
and uh you do a web series an ig series
called dis
stefano yes where you rant and rave
about chris and you
call him you know a pig and things uh
that is that that's the only thing i
call them is a pig how many episodes are
out of that
maybe 10 10 episodes yeah not a ton yeah
yeah i mean you know it's got it doesn't
have great legs
it's got some legs but i'm saying it is
ironic but it's hard to think of new
ways you're substituting for him yes yes
uh i substituted for you on the show
when you were out correct
uh
but i didn't call you a pig or anything
like that
but today i i'm calling him a pig okay
yeah let's just look this is just we
chatted up so let's just launch it be a
usual personal self
be a personable self i can't stand
that what you guys get to just coast
through this podcast but now's your
chance every week coast i know but every
week you wanna it can be a little
difficult more at times like the war
room i know we are gonna come up with
battle you
and you guys get to just waltz up here
no but sometimes it's sometimes the
structure of our show is complimentary
because you're like all right we are
something we have something to focus on
i tease that kid i know i know you do so
how do you how do you do it on this show
what happens around here oh we just
having a grand old time but i mean do
you have top guys see pimp is throwing
things up on the screen
i'll bring something off and we talk
about what we talk about but usually
it's just a an adhd
adhd riff-a-thon adh do you have adhd i
do really yeah how bad
they told me that
they told you right they said it was uh
they said it was uh
severe
severe is the word they used i think
i went for the test have you ever tested
anyone i feel like everyone thinks
they're
add adhd and uh
i felt the same way and then it got to a
point where it's like literally
affecting my life and so i made an
appointment i went in they hooked me up
to all these bands on my forehead my
ankles my feet and my legs and then i
had to watch a computer screen
and shapes would come up on the computer
screen this is in the doctor's office
and i had a mouse and i had to click on
the shape
whenever i saw it and i was like okay
and then i did it for like they leave
the room and i'm alone in the room for
like 20 minutes half hour and the shapes
come up i click shake shakes comes up i
click it right shape and
when i was done i was so nervous that
they were going to tell me because i i i
really it affects a lot of stuff i do
and i it was i was finally in there
because i said to myself i need help so
i knew i had it but when i took the test
it was so stupid and easy that i was
like oh i i got 100 on this like
whatever this is i aced it and now i'm
upset because they're going to tell me i
aced it and they're going to tell me
that i don't have this when i know i
have it right because it was nothing i
just clicked on it every time i saw a
shape
they came in they just told me they
printed out the thing they went in he
goes well you have severe adhd and i was
like how is that even possible i did it
was such an easy thing what you told me
to do and i think that maybe
it wasn't about clicking
on the thing i think it was maybe about
maybe my movement the whole time because
they put bands
all over me and so maybe i was like
fidgeting but does that mean you have
adhd i don't know here are the symptoms
here being unable to sit still
especially in calm or quiet well that's
one of them i guess i have that constant
fidgeting okay i have a bit of that
being able to unable to concentrate on
tasks 100
excessive physical movement i don't know
not necessarily
excessive talking not necessarily sort
of being unable to wait your turn wait
let me say something yeah right no not
that necessarily acting without thinking
no
i cause i think i have this sometimes
adh yeah
yeah by the way can we call this episode
adh babes
a d
h babes a-d-h-a-d-h-b
okay there you go a.d i don't know maybe
no it won't no it won't come up in a
search
uh oh my god pete davidson got kim
kardashian's name brandon on his just
pete
jesus christ he's getting his tattoos
removed and now he's he's burning her
name into his chest is it real this
doesn't help everyone who thinks she's
like in a satanic cult
do people think she's in a satanic
called i know nothing uh
i mean
it remains to be seen that's so that's
so that's silly talk though right
but yeah that's i mean that is uh i mean
that's not a tattoo that's a branded so
he burned it into his chest
how do people know that though she went
on the ellen show and told her about so
ellen's back in the picture too oh
ellen's i thought ellen left her show
ellen's back on so kim kardashian went
on the ellen show and talked and
admitted that pete branded her name yeah
and also that she he has other tattoos
on his body about her so yeah she said
he's getting them removed but also has a
few like one saying my girl's a lawyer
something like that is on one side is
she a lawyer yeah she's a lawyer or she
passed it
past the bar
she passed the bar yeah
the baby bar or maybe she did pass it
okay
i want to hear her talk about him
yeah but then he should have branded my
girl past the baby bar
yeah
my girl's a little lawyer
is that condescending little yeah
wow branding is a commitment
that's insane pete doesn't do anything
half fast probably but that's a nuts
come on
uh especially for a guy that hops around
the way he does
you know what i mean this kid is not a
settler let's be honest uh
well
that's one way to say i'm here to stay
to to the
to the people that be until you post
it's not real yeah yeah does that does
that's feel to you like that was
something that you needed to do just to
get it out of the way like it was people
were waiting to see
that wait so ellen's back on the air
allen's fully back i didn't know and i
want to be like oh my god we're so cute
and i want you know but then i'm like
you know
she
one of the most evil people on planet
earth ellen
i heard stories when i worked in that
lot when her show was going really
strong i heard stories about ellen left
and right
i heard i heard
i have heard two ellen stories that's
how it works i got a lot
in in l.a
you
you don't hear much but what you do here
is about you never hear about good stuff
you hear about the shows where there's
nightmare things happening so i heard i
would hear about ellen
i'm so sorry that you guys just had to
deal with joe derosa i'm here now i know
it's like
i don't know if somebody got i mean i
don't know if i'm sure people were
vomiting and i apologize like if you
guys want you know we can give you some
money for new clothes or if you vomited
in your car i apologize for that i know
it's repulsive um but i i i had a i had
a fever phoebe weavey um and um i just
couldn't make it to this to the to the
show so joe derosa filled in even though
i was like i'd rather not have an
episode go out than have joe derosa fill
in but sal was like we have to have it
come out so joe that i you know i guess
i do it thank you
lesbian for um
for filling in but i'm here now daddy's
home daddy's here now and uh and and no
kidding thanks joe i appreciate it i i
went to joe derosa's sandwich up
yesterday and i ate just the cold cuts
and and when you eat just the cold cuts
it doesn't taste as good um
but sorry uh actually the yeah you know
today with the day we're filming this is
actually april fool's day so that all
that was just big april fool's joke that
was april fool's episode it's just big
april fool's joke that we have derozan
co-host i'm here it's me it was april
fools i'm here i'm queer and i'm here
sal is not here um by the way you know
you know what's crazy about
what just things like
i'm just i was like great
so
all i've ever in my life it's just so
funny how backyard borrowers keeps
[ __ ] me at every turn they're they
all i've ever wanted in my entire life
is to go to the final four all i've ever
want to do in my life is go to the final
four
i've never went once i've also never
been to new orleans
all i've ever want to do is go to new
orleans i love new orleans i've always
wanted to see that city and they have
really no comedy there so i never went
and go to the final four has been like
goals goals goals
this year
for
the first and only year true tv sent all
of their tv shows of course including
practical jokers to the final four and
have them all sitting courtside and all
doing things around the final four for
true tv big promo all that stuff
and because i said sal where are you
going this weekend he said go to the
farm before i said ooh fun for you know
like that's cool like you're gonna take
your family down he goes no i'm going
for work i was like oh like just the
jokers he goes no actually all of true
tv's going i was like yeah
i was like i um i'm gonna be uh
i'll be on highland boulevard in staten
island
just trying to um not throwing myself
into traffic so i just want to say
quickly real quickly uh beggar borrowers
i'm sorry if you want to get last minute
just get me down there i'm listening
um i'll even fly coach no i um
i uh yeah so it's just [ __ ] me once
again um but what can you do it happens
but that so so he he's down in new
orleans i'm here uh at
as pimp co coined it chaos manor um and
hey guess what um uh it's it happened
last week by the time this because this
comes out next week right yeah thursday
it happens you know it happened last
week but the united states back in the
world cup baby italy didn't make it
united states may we haven't been in the
world cup since 2014 the last time the
united states was in the world cup guess
what happened the very last time the
united states was in the world cup on
their very last game the game that got
eliminated
chrissy got drunk
went out to a little bar called place to
beach
met delilah and violence mama jasmine
had sex and has kids so
this year for this year for the
uh united states final game i think it's
only right to go out there
and i think it's a holy right to go out
there and
what should we do you know what i'm
gonna go out there and i'm gonna have
sex with a transgender person that's
what i do because i've evolved i've
evolved and technically
she can't give me any [ __ ] it's not
cheating my opinion is this if you or i
respect whomever wants to be trans but
if you were born a biological male and i
go down on you it's not cheating
sal's probably so happy not to be here
for this part oh yeah this is hey babe
sorry oh yeah yeah sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry this is hey babe this is hey
babe um now that i said that i confirmed
that from three people i know i'm never
gonna be on the ellen show you why would
you what if she wants me to come on then
this comes
across from this denim nightmare
look at her face look at the expression
she's making in kim kardashian talking
about how she found love look at the
hatred
dear god dude she's she's she looks evil
man like it's wild but like that pixie
cut it makes her almost look a little
keebler i said it
yes she does she looks like any other
well there's a pixie it's a whole lesson
e l e l e l l e o e l e e fudge
e-l-l-e-n
everybody loves alan i don't know anyway
uh well i don't dislike her but i i used
to like when she first when i first saw
her doing stand up a long time ago i was
like oh i kind of i kind of think i was
never really a huge fan of herself but
she seemed like a pleasant lady and
she's funny and everything and like
i've heard i've heard real nasty story
but that's the other thing you don't get
to be like a billionaire if you're not
if you if you're not a certain type of
um personality right she's a walking
brand
yeah like you know what i mean she's a
she's a walking corporation okay it's
like that you know what i'm saying like
as is kim kardashian yeah but kim's
famous for different i'm not saying
kim's nuts i never met her what amount
of money do you do you think you become
evil by accident but i don't think it's
by accident i think you have to like i i
would give i'm not just saying this
because she dates pete i would give kim
kardashian a pass because she's not
famous through her own
she's famous because she stumbled into
it in a weird way like her dad was
famous and her mom
yeah and then like the show got on tv
you know what i mean it's a little bit
different
i think when you're somebody like ellen
where it's like you're like no i'm doing
this solo and my goal is to get up there
and you you get to the top of that mount
that's why i don't think you're a
sociopath because
i'm being honest you you and the guys
have quite a bit of fame i mean you're
known you're famous okay
but it's not because you didn't you
didn't sit and go and then
you know what i mean you did a thing
yeah
yeah yeah yeah i mean little thing the
thing got picked up the thing exploded
is that what anyone does no no there are
people that strategize i just think
they climb the mountain i just think two
things happen you either lose sight a
little bit because you're surrounded by
people that just yes you to death and
stuff like that or you were that person
that was not equipped for it to begin
with
you know not everybody's equipped for it
i don't know one person
who went the route that ellen went
and has gotten anywhere near her
stratosphere of success
that is not
a sociopath
i mean
that just goes without saying so like
oprah elon musk uh look at oprah oprah
goes on tv and goes way to fight for our
women and then she's checking out with
harvey weinstein it's like
what are we talking about
what are we talking about post
everything no no it was during but every
single person that
came out after that he got busted said
we all knew this was going on hey babe
hi i don't know where at the chrissy
chaos matter filling in for hey babe
because jojo rosa ruins everything
you know they just said this is just
happening live but jada pinkett had a
response she broke her silence jada
pinken about what happened last week at
the oscars the hay babe audience has
heard nothing about this hey babe
doesn't know about this yeah oh yeah yes
um um
we're here go google jada pinkett smith
break silence let's see what jada let's
see what jada said jada pinka
i know wow that why homeless pimp just
did something he put i said jaden
pickett smith break science he put
j-a-d-e-a and j-e-d-e-n p-i-n-k break
science and the internet said you need
to do better if we have no search
results
what did jada pinkett's smith say
broker science tuesday cited healing
this is the season for healing and i'm
here for jada
you said nothing again
oh my god is she getting trashed in the
comments let's see i mean could you
imagine posting this [ __ ]
i mean
oh god she looks evil yo evil as can be
oh my god heart queen right here
up vanity i commented
[Laughter]
um
no i mean come on
like
why do you feel do you guys do you feel
pimpy that celebrity is losing its power
no that it's lost its power to children
like i when i go to see my 13 year old
sister like they believe in them more
than they believe in their own family
interesting no you're about to witness
it when you have these teenagers in this
house yeah that they trust the word of
tick-tockers more than they give a [ __ ]
tick-tockers but i'm talking about
actors and actresses
your sister same celebrity to them to
them that's the same people well yeah
because i noticed because when i was
watching um
when i was watching euphoria i googled
some of the people that i'm like oh you
know not thinking all of them have 10
million instagram followers to even the
guy fez the guy that plays fez in the
show he was serving brunch in brooklyn
two three years ago and now he's got
nine million followers on instagram from
this is his only role so it's like that
show
for the youth is like that's a viral
show yeah and some of them started bands
in their music festivals so these kids
are smart they know how to capitalize on
the celebrity i don't think celebrities
going anywhere how does zendaya she's
been an actress for 10 years in the
public eye and she always plays a 16
year old for the last 10 years she's
consistently played a 16 year old i
don't know how the hell i like zendaya
zendaya isn't is one of the only actor
actresses i've seen
she's not trans right she's a girl
dying or a girl i don't know who that is
she she identifies as a female and she's
dating that spider-man guy
tom holland correct i thought he was gay
gay gay well he's uh straight trade
straight within diet i heard tom holland
i thought tommy holland was fully
i thought he was a gay man
isn't it
from new york
um i don't know but she's a disney kid
disney oh so she's been in the game a
long time because what i like about
zendaya what she has to me is palpable
likability through her acting it's like
she's so likable tom holland is open to
the idea of spider-man coming out ah tom
holland spider-man is gay but as a
person he's straight spider-man's
definitely good yo spider-man is gay
yeah
spider-man is gay those websites that's
just come that he shoots out of his
hands runs around the city shoot and
come that's what it is um
the fact that hey babe the fact that tom
holland isn't gay
is pretty mind-blowing to me right now
but people say that about you
yeah
yeah i get it
i get i'm almost sad that i'm not gay
all right listen guys rowback this
company wrote back give this a little
symbol right here i'm honestly telling
you the truth
best shirt i've ever had this
performance hoodie i'm wearing it like
hides my nipple fat like you can't
imagine i've been wearing you're going
to notice on every podcast you're going
to see that symbol that's rollback uh
the kfc guys from barstool mentioned it
everybody's mentioning it these this
shirt is like legit dope they got
performance hoodies performance polos uh
performance q-zips the material is
insane i feel like i'm just going to
work and i feel like i'm a
five-star athlete and it just fits my
body right you know me baby i'm chrissy
nooks and crannies i got fat in all
these little nooks and grannies and roll
back covers them all up i truthfully
love this shirt the material is sick
like look at this just the material is
dope comes in nice packaging nice nice
nice colors to bring out the color in
your eyes and in all honesty roll back
has been getting traction big time we
see the big dog we see that dog logo
everywhere and who doesn't love dogs
honestly dude if you're a cat person
that's the thing if you're a cat person
you're a little creepy for me so you can
just go wear another shirt but if you're
a dog lover which you gotta love dogs to
be a normal human being then go with
throwback there's the beautiful dog on
the shoulder it's nicely placed and
right now if you use the code babe all
right guys and you're going to get a
great discount if you go to
rollback.com that's
r-h-o-b-a-c-k.com and use the promo code
babe
b-a-b-e promo code b-a-b-e babe
roback.com 20 off your first order
through the end of this week all polos
q-zips and hoodies and teas with code
babe b-a-b-e
rollback.com go get the hoodies
all right what do you want to eat
tonight babe maybe you want to have a
home-cooked favorite but don't feel like
going to the store or maybe you want
something inside and new but it would be
great to stay in let me tell you who can
handle both of them door dash baby it
connects you with everything you want
whenever and however you want along with
the restaurants you love you can now get
groceries and other essential items
delivered with doordash get drinks
snacks and other household items in
under an hour with over 300 000 partners
you can support your neighborhood
go-to's or choose your favorite natural
restaurants like popeyes chipotle and
the cheesecake factory for a limited
time our listeners can get 20
i'm sorry 25 so not even 20 25 that's
how great door dish is for limited time
and zero delivery fees on the first
order of 15 or more when you download
the doordash app and enter the code hey
babe h-e-y-b-a-b that's 25 off up to 10
value and zero delivery fees on your
first order when you download the
doordash app in the app store and enter
the code hey babe h-e-y-b-a-b-e don't
forget that's code hey babe for
twenty-five percent of your first order
with door dash subject to change terms
apply you know i just like no i'm not
i'm trying to be
but i just know i'm forgotten i'm trying
i've got i'm just really trying to think
about it i really try to get gay i try
to do like bought key goals and i just
try to like i mean look at this look at
my shoes i'm wearing and it just doesn't
feel right these sneakers by the way
they um i stole them from a photo shoot
and they are called landon's are they
called mike lavins what are they called
i don't know they yes something landon's
lap they're nice they but they they they
go up and it feels like i'm wearing a
high heel but it's a sneaker i think
this is how you should go close shopping
from now on why three pants
zara sweatshirt photo shoot and steal it
i stole everything and then the silas
flew to tokyo was like just keep it
[ __ ] yeah and i ripped one of the
jackets right down the back really it
was like a 800 jacket chris farley yeah
i just ripped it right down the back i
was like
dude it's crazy though that there's a
shirt i had to put on for the photo
shoot a shirt that's six hundred dollars
like
have you ever bought a piece of clothing
that not shoes clothes that's six
hundred dollars i was investing in my
life i was in vegas with you and i went
to all the designer stores i
almost bought a versace shirt that was
2500.
whoa it was fire it's f i could easily
if i had real money i could easily but
my question is if you wash that and it
shrinks you're done
yeah you you don't wash those times i
bring it to a dry cleaner like a like
and not like just any dry cleaner like
there's a professional yeah i'd probably
research who to bring it to you yeah
cause that i mean a 2500 what if you get
a stain on it what if it rips i'm gonna
drop dead soon whatever
so if you had a 2500 shirt and there was
a cigarette hole in it you wouldn't
throw you would just be like all right
the shirt would morph with you all i do
is work i'm wearing the 2500 shirt to
film you at a show somewhere i genuinely
believe in my heart i genuinely in my
heart in the past 10 years i haven't
purchased clothes that would accumulate
up to 2 500 bucks not shoes i'm talking
about clothes i know sneakers can get
expensive i'm talking about clothes what
do you spend on like a polo or a button
up
dollars he rocks the h m and you rock it
well like because it's just basics like
at the end of the day like if you know
how to dress well you're fine basic dead
ass like [ __ ] brand i'm really hate
brands [ __ ] brands i'm a basic [ __ ] how
about old navy queen basically you just
yelled lululemon for like two years
straight
but is lululemon basic or that's real
[ __ ] oh it's basic basic
like that's basic because the pants are
120 bucks but it's based i mean it's
just for hot girls to work out in have
you heard of marnie before no marnie
internet is that no caller id maybe this
is chad's palmetto i know
he'll say something crazy this is hey
babe uh if we were on the chrissy chaos
patreon yeah no it's m-a-r-n-i
m-a-r-n-i um
and then the other one they had me in
was kenzo
kenzo i've heard of yeah marny look 2
450 reversible shirt she's fired it's
reversible so it's like two shirts got
the fringe
yeah yo look at that would you buy that
would you could you see me in that for
real i could see you in there yeah they
got a 200 ashtray
all right this is ridiculous i mean
you've never been a real rich people
this is enough this is nothing man the
hamptons they'd be wearing like four
thousand dollar shoes i will say one
thing about more expensive clothing
because i have my little y3 pants right
now
even though my body because i have a
certain type of body type
it they the clothes fit me like the more
expensive the like it fits like it fits
your body right so there is something to
that where like you buy cheaper stuff it
just is bag like everything fits my body
like even the monitor it's like tight to
my arms like it hides everything and i
was like last longer so that's enough
it's an investment in your clothes i do
agree with like investing in your
clothes and stuff like it's not gonna
rip that shirt like it's good ass
material yeah i think do not dry it
don't do not wash it here bring that to
a dry cleaner correct okay and then
maybe ask the dry cleaner how to handle
it you know what's crazy you know what i
just thought of i i have a a michael
kors jacket that i brought to the dry
cleaner in december
it's march
do that are they going to have it or is
it gone oh my god i hope this is just
like they not called you i hope there's
just a kid called
my phone number where they have the
wrong number
in like in brooklyn no on staten island
we should call well they have i don't
even remember where it was we should go
there now i don't have the ticket it's
gone
no
we should i love that coat
you never bought designer clothes as a
basketball player
no no never dude
i used to wear my basketball warm-ups
like out i never and it's not like i
think oh
i i just don't even know what to buy
what to do like like if you ask me i've
been in new york city my whole life if
you ask me where's like a good clothes
store to get clothes in new york city
i'd be like the adidas store i don't
know i would i have have you ever been
to a designer clothing store
i don't even know what a design oh what
is so funny what is an example of a
designer clothes store in new york city
gucci louis vuitton like where are they
all over the city you just have to look
for them
like would you go like down broadway
like by soho is that where like all
those oh has a lot of yeah soho's packed
with it the only thing i've ever went
into is a fry boot store and i bought
fry boots where are those there's a good
phase those are up in my no when was the
last time you really wore them
yo i didn't think i wore those fry boots
all winter
yeah you forgot it i'll give the
pandemic
yeah i forgot like i forgot all that
stuff i can't believe i forgot my jacket
so when you go clothes shopping what's
your objective i go to h m and i just
ask if they have double xl's and 38's
38 i mean i've seen the things that
you've picked they look great except for
that striped shirt but everything else
looks amazing
the one you wore oh yeah the freddy
krueger sweater yep sorry no no don't
say sorry it's your style but zara is
gonna be my new look i'm gonna
compromise with zara zara i was told by
v i was told by other fashionistas that
zara
is the next level up from h m i've
graduated from zara so we gonna do zara
now i love zara let's go to zara now
guys let's go to zara and are you still
moisturizing yes i'm still moisturizing
and because i stayed at the soho house
which i got um a free membership for
from doing a corporate kick just because
joe rogan's listening is i
is they have they they had a bag on my
bed on if you stay at the so house the
one i stayed in austin it's called soho
skin and they gave me more moisturizers
and creams and a little for the i've
been traveling non-stop for five years
this is the first time where i have an
airport i have a little zip bag for all
my toiletries i usually just throw them
in my bag and have to find them there'd
always be toothpaste or deodorant on a
shirt because i just would throw it in
there like an idiot but now i have an
actual bag that they gave me so the soho
house thank you you remember yearly
membership was worth the airport bag you
gave me you really do move around like
the tasmanian devil i know dude i gotta
be better
all right listen well we gotta i gotta
go eat a sandwich
let's go back to joe derosa
how do you get to that level of fame
whether it's in entertainment or
politics which is which is one of the
same right folks
but how do you get how do you get to
that level without being a sociopath
yeah i don't know you can't it's insane
you can't it's insane it's saying i
deserve this i deserve to be watched in
every household around the globe but you
know they deserve to be the president of
the united states it's psychotic
well a lot of that level starts to get
ego driven like in like in the wrong in
a bad way no
i think it can i think best case
scenario was this
what what are you were you laughing at
no just it's so funny you abused me why
what did i do nothing i i liked hearing
your rants
i don't necessarily what's in the giant
mason jar
that was also a funny like we paused and
just listened to you slurped through the
ice for a little bit
you did it on stage you take a sip at
the wrong moment you just like [ __ ] man
everyone's done laughing and you just
you just pick it up and then john
laughing and then you just like go go go
go go
all right i picked my drink up and put
it down without sipping it so frequently
on stage because you're because of the
timing it's like double dutch when
you're gonna take a sip on stage yeah it
is you just like should i do it i pick
it up i go right back i put it like that
the uh but no i'm saying like the the
i think the best case scenario is this
you are self-centered enough
to think you deserve this
and as you go like pimp said let more
and more yes people get around you and
unless people are saying no
right and then that can barrel out of
control
but it is never not starting from a
place of of
vast ego like vast ego these are not
these are not people
that go home and go
these are not people that process the
the dark thoughts in in
in a healthy way you know what i mean
like you can process the dark thoughts
in a bad way you can process the dark
thoughts by beating yourself up and
stunting your own success trust me i
know
but this is what they they go they so
the opposite direction where it's just
like you know it like i don't know i
find it fascinating you know who do you
know that's a sociopath that's not
famous name they can't name names well
this is it name name know a lot buddy
this is this is it we know
just put those little bars over our
mouths and we'll just talk for you
now um it's we we know so many we know
so many yeah i know so many people that
have something really wrong with them a
new poll is out that says one in 100
people are a sociopath oh that's a lot
new york is just ground zero social pets
everywhere
damn
i mean it's i mean look we all have a
degree of it right
do we though we all have a and then you
think you're
business we all have some degree of it i
don't know if i wouldn't know if i
called myself a sociopath maybe i'm not
using the correct term but my point is
is we have some sort of ego complex well
i don't even i think it's over i think
it's everyone because of social media
that's that's what's causing it that's
insane that too but i just was on
vacation and i watched i was sitting in
the ocean
and i watched these three girls
and for i watched them for two hours
straight go along the beach to different
spots and all do a photo shoot for each
other
it took two hours the middle of the day
blazing sun and they were just
changing their positions making like
this whole thing where they're not
looking at the camera but they're like
looking down at the sand like and
they're like going like that or they're
going like that i'm just like and
there's all people around and they're
just doing it right in front of them
like there's not even any shame in it i
think we need to bring back self-hatred
full photo shoots and then when one was
done the other one would go and then the
one girl the third girl didn't go at all
i think she was like the lackey
you know i think like the other girl was
like an influencer or something or they
she she was rich and she brought the
other two girls her parents paid for it
they were like and it just was like the
one girl was just her job was to
photograph the other girl i enjoy that
girl that's the person i enjoy the one
who photographs yeah yeah i was just
like i can't believe this i watch them
then i watch them there then i watch
them down the beach there then i watch
them over there and i just was like i
can't believe they're spending the day
doing the same shots over and over and
over nuts dude it's not i feel weird
putting a picture of myself online i do
it once in a while yeah but it's never
serious have you ever met someone
because i've been meeting new people and
they're like
talking down to me because they're tick
tock famous but they don't know who i am
they're just acting famous
and they have like maybe a hundred
thousand yeah
yeah yeah
tick tock is fairly easy to get
most of it's spam yeah for the most part
this is w
i realize what i would love
i would love to see a joe derosa tick
tock page never going to happen i mean i
have an account i think i have six
followers yeah i don't do but i would
love to see you do like the tick tock
stuff oh yeah
i think it would become very famous
because you're so not that
but but but it wouldn't become famous
because i'm not i wouldn't be committing
to it
and then there's no joke no you need to
go the joke is me doing it begrudgingly
yeah i don't know i have one too i never
do it i don't i don't
i don't that's not how i want to
communicate to people it's not i don't i
was like i should do it because if i'm
actually on it and people think it's me
engaging i could build up the numbers
and have another outlet for a social
platform for things but it's like i
can't bring myself to i got nothing to
say it's weird you know it's just a
weird i don't understand it um i should
right
i should do it
should should could would whatever you
know what am i gonna do reaction videos
like you react to the videos but so it's
that's wild that people want to see me
react to another video yep so you do it
i thought a duet was to like is it duet
to react so you could it's picture in
picture or whatever so you have one
playing and then you react to it and
then people watch you reacting to other
people yeah they want definitely from
you they would want are you serious
what the [ __ ] the big deal so what
about if i react to people's reaction
reaction reaction videos
do people do that
do people do that
it just seems like what are we doing
like there should be other things to
focus on besides watching people react
to other people people don't underst
people i realized this the other day
we're living in a bridge generation
right now
all right it sounds like we're like
get off my lawn right no it's not though
night is darkest before the dawn we're
in the dark right now
this is we're we're teetering on
whatever the next phase of of reality
and accepted reality and and known
reality is we're not there yet this is
the part where everything is real wonky
and real ugly before it happens this is
pre this is 10 years 20 years whatever
before the industrial revolution
[ __ ] is crazy it's it's gangs in new
york like what the [ __ ] is going on out
here when you think that's gonna that
damn's gonna break i think in about 20
to 50 years from now we're gonna see
a real change where people are finally
coming into their own
and and you know you're not seeing this
of evolution of of
of the generations that are trying to
accept it and exploit it you know this
tick tock thing all of this [ __ ] social
media all of it it will burn out
and eventually evolve into what it's
supposed to be you know what i mean
which is a maggot is a maggot and then
it turns into a butterfly or whatever
you know what i'm saying
or a word
what becomes a butterfly caterpillar
yeah
yeah disgusting a disgusting [ __ ]
caterpillar
becomes a beautiful butterfly right now
we're the disgusting caterpillar
all right and everything every you see
everybody doing with all this wonderful
technology that they could be doing so
much good for the world and it's being
just used for self-indulgence and vanity
and all these other things primarily
there is good stuff out there but you
have to really dig for it
that's the caterpillar it's going to be
it's going to go into a cocoon and
become a butterfly but we're not in the
cocoon yet we're just not
[Laughter]
it's so serious talking about it's just
so funny to me did you ever get serious
like this on this show not really
but we did we did launch into like stuff
that i don't really talk i never really
talk about like pop cult person you guys
know that your internet provider like
verizon spectrum can keep logs of your
internet activity that includes stuff
like the sites you visited how much time
you spent on them and even worse the gov
can get them to cough up this
information whenever they want but when
you buy expressvpn which i've been using
for years now your internet activity is
shielded their app works by rerouting
100 of your network data through their
secure encrypted servers to keep your
private your privacy and active so
here's the thing i use it on my phone
and i use it on my laptop and my work
laptop i just got it it's there it runs
in the background you could disable it
by hitting a button it's just red and
green it's super simple and uh yeah i
mean i i like knowing that i have it you
use one pim vpn yeah yeah expressvpn
yeah yeah i like i once i had like
before i had it after i had it i do feel
like i could rest a little easier i just
don't want people minding all that stuff
for me at all oh yeah it's happening too
unlike the kill switch the government
wants to put in all of our cars which i
don't know what that is because i'm not
research there but this is what
expressvpn is telling me
expressvpn's kill switch actually
protects you if your vpn connection ever
drops network data is immediately
stopped from entering or leaving your
device that's true i even get the little
uh notification when that happens all it
takes is one easy tap of a button for
expressvpn to secure all your online
devices or all of your devices in
general so stop letting the government
spy on you take back your privacy and
freedom at
expressvpn.com hey babe and get three
months three extra months free that's
expressvpn that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n.com
slash hey babe expressvpn
hey babe guys let's talk current chrissy
uses it he loves it um it's basically an
app he uses it's got a real and it's
easy to use it's intuitive he uses it to
track his spending and uh and and
actually for faster direct deposit uh
he's been loving it
current is is basically they're they are
the future of ben banking babes
current's mobile app and connected debit
card help you get ahead by giving you
faster access to your paychecks fewer
fees more flexibility benefits include
uh things like creating savings goals um
so like if you're someone who is bad
with managing your money they can help
you understand how you can save uh there
are no withdrawal fees oh and over 40
000 in network atms so that's kind of
cool uh and yeah you earn points you can
earn points and you can cash back
rewards like every other card so that's
cool they do that current just launched
their newest feature current members are
now able to earn four
percent annual percentage yield apy on
savings okay 60 times on savings pods
that's 60 times the national average
yeah my savings account's like .001 it's
ridiculous any member who signs up for a
current personal account can start
earning that apy daily by adding money
to the savings pod and enabling the
interest feature that's it members can
seamlessly transfer money between
savings pods and their spending balance
there are no lockout periods and there
are no fees for the feature or balance
minimum requirements to access so that
is just ready to go uh for a limited
time we've partnered with current to
give away a thousand bucks that's right
current is going to give away 250 bucks
to four different listeners of hey babe
all you have to do is download the
current app at
current.com remember that's current.com
hey babe the giveaway closes april 20th
so don't wait uh download the current
app and be entered to win at current.com
hey babe there's no purchase necessary
to win purchase won't increase the
chances of winning voidware prohibited
eligibility restrictions apply visit
current.com for full terms and
conditions m
i gotta read this part guys so brace but
i'm i'm going to read a little quick
current is a financial technology
company not a bank banking services
provided by uh visa debit card issued by
choice financial group member fdic
pursuant to a license from visa usa inc
and can be used everywhere visa debit
cards are accepted the annual percentage
yield apy for current interest is
variable and may change at any time the
disclosed apy is effective as of january
1 2022 no minimum balance is required
must have at least point zero one cent
in savings pods to earn current interest
uh on up to two thousand dollars in
deposits per savings pot up to six
thousand dollars total please refer to
current interest terms and conditions 60
times rate calculated using the fdic
average national deposit rate for
savings accounts of
0.06
what are you most ashamed about crying
over
i i well up at a lot of stuff
a lot of people the most
ashamed i was was when i took my parents
to see rise of skywalker and it was the
second time i saw it and i was hiding my
tears throughout the movie
are you serious that's serious wow
orlando he answered your question when
lando showed up with the millennium
falcon i was crying like a [ __ ] baby
i had to hide it from my parents
sitting between my parents
i could cry at any show and i carry
commercials
but there's not been one where you're
like i'm so glad no one's seeing this no
it's i mean it's got to be i cry often
i cry often it's got to be i'm ashamed
like i don't want to see i don't know i
don't know i was sobbing one time in a
sad movie like 20 years ago it's
probably terrible now it's already not
that bad but i was so sad i was crying
at this part and i there was only like
six people in the theater and then
somebody laughed at what happened
someone was getting hung in
in the movie and uh and and i was like
and the guy was there and he was in like
the town square it wasn't like old times
it was like someone they went abroad and
there was these strict rules and then
and the government threw them in jail
and they were they were trying to get
lawyers to get them out for years and
stuff and then they they were going to
hang them and
there was someone there like there's no
doubt he was getting hung and so they
were there and they were like looking at
him through the
through the square and they were like
like kind of connecting with him and be
like i'm right here i'm right here for
you and like the guy knew he was about
to get hungry they were just like trying
to comfort him in that moment like
screaming to him from far away to like
just stay here with us and i was crying
i forgot the name of it
it's like joaquin phoenix i think it
gets hung is it a cowboy movie i don't
know no no no no
i
it probably isn't said now i think it
was like vince vaughn speaking of ellen
i think ann heyche was in it isn't it
his her wife no her old one
old yeah
oh oh you're talking about you're
talking about the movie where they go to
like
they're like backpacking yeah and they
leave the weed and then the guy gets
yeah and they have to go back and fight
it's called welcome to paradise
something like that i just remember in
that moment i was like oh my god this is
so upset and someone laughed and i was
like what a piece of [ __ ]
but i also will cry like you know that
show like move the bus
and the bus drives away and like the
homeless family has a new house it was
behind the bus the whole time what
with the guy with the tan he's got a
crazy tan he's the host he's like this
guy with like spiky hair it used to be a
big show and they were like oh you know
this family you know the down on their
luck and the kid the five kids sleep in
the same room and they always wish they
had a surround celebration by the house
for the hospital and then the bus moves
and the whole space the whole i know you
met the bus move to reveal a homeless
family living on the side
that's what i thought you meant
you know like
that's it hey i used to cry my ass off
at that have you guys ever cried in the
streets oh yeah the streets will get you
in the streets oh anything can get me in
the streets somebody goes someone could
pass by in a
i said let's talk about it in the sheets
someone could pass by in a car with a
song on the song will make me tear up i
cried uh in the i was at south by
southwest last week and i saw a preview
of the kids in the hall documentary and
i wept like a baby at one part in that
like like a baby no
it's truly like
i actually can't remember devastatingly
emotional every day when i wake up and i
look at all the alerts for my news
alerts like half of them make me want to
[ __ ] get be so depressed
it's like you can't wake up to this like
i look at the news like when i wake up
and usually like when i'm going to bed
it's like the wrong time to look at the
news the uh i mean you're starting your
day off with tragedy after tragedy and
going to bed with it that's like i don't
even want to disconnect from that [ __ ]
but it's hard because you also want to
be you know up to date with [ __ ] let me
let me take to change the topic why i'm
enjoying this okay
i like talking about stuff like this you
do yeah okay
yeah
go ahead it's your show no it's not my
show it's our show no it's your show
it's not
i don't own a piece of this show you do
own
this is yours today it's our show okay
that's very nice of you yeah
um
did i ever tell you the story about when
i got um accidentally i got mail
delivered to my house that wasn't mine i
did it on this is not happening on ari's
show i think so i got i got this package
it was from ann taylor
loft which is like a women's clothing
store right it was like this and uh
nothing strange yet
no
and it had the woman's name on it and it
had
my address but
it the woman didn't live in my home
right so i was like oh this is messed up
i gotta give this to back to the uh to
the
the what
it's about postman post
sometimes i actually you know i don't
know what's happening i thought i did
something that you thought no so it's
like what's it to the person the postal
worker
the postman is posting the post
personally you should say
the best why gender i'm like i'm gonna
give back to him right at two weeks
passed by and i didn't do it and then a
snow st we had a huge snowstorm and i
was in the house like three days and i
was a little stir crazy and so i was
like i'm gonna open these open this and
see what it is i have an idea i'll open
it if there's a receipt in there
sometimes it's a packing slip with the
person's email or phone number in there
so i opened it and there was a pair of
pants women's pants it was size six
satin black
pants
women's dress pants and it had the
woman's name in it and it had her email
address
so
i was like i'm gonna email her right now
and tell her i have a pants okay
but then i was like kind of like just
stir crazy and i was like you know what
how funny would it be
if i wrote her a ransom note for her
pants instead it's just a pair of pants
like a terrible idea they're just a pair
of pants right so i was like that'll be
funny so i got all my magazines
and i it took me a little over five
hours
and i cut the letters and i taped them
it was like a 20-page ransom note i was
loopy and i wrote like i have your pants
if you ever want to see them again
you'll listen to what i have to tell you
uh you will you will meet me here like a
terrible idea so i know
at the time i didn't have anyone to my
friend just was like this is great and i
did it and i was like you have to bring
me uh an unmarked duffle bag you have to
bring me this honey peanut butter skippy
honey peanut butter i was just making a
joke uh there's so much on the screen i
want to refer to right now go ahead you
not want me to finish my story sorry i
got distracted i'm sorry i'm sorry i
just saw something that referred back to
what we were just talking about though
so i wrote the whole ransom no no joke
is about 20 pages i scanned it
and i put it in the email and i just
sent the email and they put in the
subject line i have your pants
and then she got the ransom note
i i went to bed i didn't think anything
of it the next morning i woke up she had
written to me and she was like actually
furious she was like who are you what is
this
why would you even write me this this is
out of line i don't know who you think
you are yep i'm i'm 100 right i'm gonna
call i'm gonna forward this to the cops
i'm gonna call the authorities i think
she might even said the fbi and she's
like this is harassment and
just
send me my [ __ ] pants and all that
stuff and i was like oh my god i wasn't
expecting her to come in hot like that
and so i was just like
what do i do and so i
i
i just wrote back do you think i'm
playing games oh come on
and then i did a photo shoot in her
pants
and
i i put her pants on i got i got i it
took me about three minutes but i slowly
got into the side sick pants and i
zipped them up and i was and they they
came up to like here on me and they were
super tight and i was gonna take photos
but i was bare chested i was like this
is gonna this might look weird so i put
on a suit but i used her pants so i put
on a tie a jacket and i put on a suit
and i was like all right now i'm going
to take pictures in my pants i'm going
to send it with the emails as you think
i'm playing games with you right and i
was like wait my face is in this so i
put on a schematic did you have the tv
show at this point by the way
yes
so i put on i put on a ski mask okay i
put on a ski mask and i take photos of
myself in the suit with her pants on and
i send that in the email okay
and she doesn't write back oh damn
really
yeah uh
a couple of days later
i get a text from my landlord who lives
downstairs
and he says just hey buddy uh any chance
did you get a a package delivered at any
point uh to you it should have come
downstairs it was for my girlfriend
so i know his name that's not her name
that's why it didn't resonate with me
and he goes it's it's for my girlfriend
they were pants
and it was my [ __ ] landlord's
girlfriend who i wrote a ransom note to
who i told her you think i'm playing
games and i harassed her and she
threatened me with the fbi
so i was like oh my god
i actually have the pants can you meet
me outside i have a funny story to tell
you like just hoping like it's not going
to be like he's not going to evict me
and then i went outside and i'm like
here's the pants and he's like thank you
so much and i was like but also i was
like i gotta tell you something i
thought it would be funny
uh last week to
i opened the pants up to see who they
belong to i didn't recognize his name i
put them on i did a photo shoot in them
and i wrote a ransom note and i sent
them in an email to whoever this is
addressed to which happens to be a
girlfriend and he goes
what and i was like yeah i did all that
i was like i just thought it would be
funny and he was like
okay
and i was like so
how do you want to handle this
i was like you know like you got to tell
her that i'm sorry and all that stuff
and he's like uh yeah i guess i'll just
tell her then so i was like all right
and then he left and then like i didn't
see her for a real long time i never met
her before and then one day like a long
time like not long after that like
months i forget what it was i was
walking out of my front door and it was
in a house she lived downstairs and she
was walking up the driveway
and i knew it was her because
for reasons i won't say but i knew that
it was her and like we kind of stopped
and she was like
are you the guy that had my pants oh
yeah jesus cried and then i and i just
said to her i never got that peanut
butter
[Laughter]
and she didn't really laugh and then she
went inside and it was a mortifying
story and i did it on this is not
happening yeah you did it here too just
now it's all true yeah
my point is the whole thing just my
point is we gotta watch the clip just
now okay yeah i got a package delivered
to a place that is supposed to be uh
about
it's it's not my address but it's the
right block but it's not my address and
it was delivered in
january 15th
and i didn't know what it was i opened
it up it is a pair of women's pants
this is that where i lived before is
another house this is not her pants
it's a pair of [ __ ] women's pants
and it is
the same thing has happened to me all
over again it is red
leather pants
from whatever that company is blue
revival
it's like maroon leather women's pants
again what are the odds that i got
women's pants sent to my house again
what do you think the universe is
telling you well this happened this this
happened this happened in like 2000
like 15 or something and i kind of think
i should do it to this woman too
so
i i think the universe is telling me
that i'm going to have a whole addition
to this story and it's going to become i
understand different take on it that i
don't want to say to you because i'm
afraid it's going to freak you out
why
i think somebody sent you these pants
because they saw that this is not
happening no they didn't send it to me
this is someone else's address they i
got they got erroneously delivered to my
address okay that's so it's not your
address with a different name it is not
my address with a different name this
one has actually got delivered wrong but
it's okay
it's for a house uh close by well the
last time you did it did you have a good
year after
a good year yeah
was it good luck you think i don't think
i had a good year
that wasn't a bad year but
what i'm saying is i didn't open these
yet but i want to open them and i might
want to get into them
and i might want to write this woman
another rant don't just let it go what's
the size through there what's a size 24
it's two is it european
it's small
how's the size 24 small a size 24 in
men's is tiny what are you talking about
pants a pant
24 waist oh it's a 24 waist i don't
women's i thought women's pants were
like no no don't don't leave it alone
just send it to the address but i do
think it's telling me that i need to
know i think the universe is telling me
that i need to try these on don't zero
in with women it is so i'll never get
into it open it and see what it is on
your neck that's how you always can
check really if you put it around your
neck
that's how you measure just send it to
the button i'm not doing anything to it
i'm just going to look at them joe
respects the mail yeah it's weird i know
you're literally critical of this
no you know that's true though right no
because it doesn't have a name on it
so but it has an address on it so send
it to the address it belongs to yeah but
i can't make out what that says so
like it's cut off so i i opened it for
the same reason i opened the other one i
was looking for a an actual name i'm
sure yeah yeah yeah joe listen to me do
you want your friend to get arrested
i'm not the only one that knows the law
they all know the law but you don't need
to tell them the law
but you don't need to you don't need to
like do it you have to put it out what
are you doing
for a pants prank this doesn't make any
sense so this is it
that's wow i like them those are fun i
like them what do you think i mean
that's a weird fit
that looks like these look like pants
that would go on a pony
a small horse
yeah
i i guess i can't get into him
unless i caught him at a monophone
correct and then i get into him or i put
like one leg in
or i just i'm
talking to mike talking to mike
or i just like hold them i can't take a
picture look at the size of those
look at the size zoning and he goes i
guess i can't get into them
i guess yeah do you guess
can you get into your arm couldn't fit
is is that i think the nose is telling
me that i need to follow up with a
ransom note on these show there's so
many of you to tell us about listeners
that are going to go to jail i'm coming
let me dissect everything insane about
what you just said in one sentence first
of all let's start with the universe is
telling me the universe isn't telling
you anything
all right the universe doesn't care
about what you're doing all right i
think the universe is telling me that i
need to not that i should not that it
might be funny that i need to meaning
life or death food and water
medicine sunshine i need to right
last part of the sentence send another
another
ransom note
listen to yourself i know that it sounds
like you know didn't we just didn't you
just say all 100 people's social media
and i said everybody in entertainment to
a degree is associated
no but i just i i it's fun thank you do
you guys think do you guys think it's
just the way to live life
is to send another ransom note for these
leather pants i thought you were punk
rock thorough isn't that the way to live
life he always got arrested he almost
got arrested when she didn't know who he
was
what are you doing what do you mean i
can't even believe you're considering
this right now because i'm sorry but i'm
excited how are you going to get her a
ransom though what do you mean how am i
going to get it how are you going to get
the ransom in the tour i'm gonna put in
the mailbox
i thought you didn't have the whole
address i thought it wasn't on the mail
i'm gonna have to put in a few mailboxes
yeah really because the number because
if you have the full address you just
committed another one i didn't i'm
telling you the numbers the number gets
cut off so like you can imagine on the
block where would you put the red ransom
though i put them in all the mailboxes
oh this this idea really it's a way for
me to get them to her because i don't
know whose they are so if she if the
person writes back to me or emails me
back which i'll put in my emails oh no
she's not even gonna know what pants
you're talking about for all you know
this lady orders 10 pairs of pants a
week for all you know she ordered for
all you know she forgot she ordered
these and she thinks you're talking
about her pants that she already wears
this sounds psychotic i will name the
pants i will say the maroon leather
pants from blue envy where the hell are
they from here's what happened last time
i actually forgot to tell you he told me
he goes
she's freaking out and i didn't realize
i emailed her from my email address when
i sent this ransom note so it was my
freaking email address and there so
that's why i was like i have to cop to
it because i could lie to him but if i
lie to him and my name came through with
because the address isn't my name but if
my name came through with that address i
was going be that would look very bad so
i had to be like oh laugh with me about
this but then nobody laughed
but it was a great bit
you understand but then the world
laughed
subsequently
so i think that this is let's pull the
clip up and see if the wrong last let's
see how well the bit did you know this
is fine before we start but fine is not
the world left the bit did well well the
bit did well well
or fine well great did it do great very
good
very good yeah i would say kill
then you're out dude that's killed
we're very good at risking a rest over a
bit that's not even gonna kill very good
is not good
i i wouldn't be thinking of committing a
crime unless they led the episode off
with it
well it's because you were first in the
lineup
no he chooses it's a lot cart huh he
chooses how he's also too you you put
the weaker stuff up front you don't
close with the biggest no actually
you're wrong
actually you're wrong you lead with the
best stuff because you want a retention
uh
believe me i've been only at 10 years
buddy oh wow
i had to give it to him because he says
i'm that guy and i'm not so now i'm
serving you up where you always say i
don't think it's a good idea that you
drive to a street in staten island or
god knows wherever the hell that's from
and leave a ransom note in 10 different
mailboxes because you think one day it
might be a funny bit on a tv show that
doesn't even exist anymore no i mean a
bit on stage for stage i'll film it sal
let's go do it i honestly i believe you
guys believe he's not living life to the
fullest i live life to the fullest i
live life babe i live life
you don't and you don't want to do this
this is an adventure you got no idea
what i'm doing this is the universe
telling me to go on an adventure okay
you follow it you follow the ripple
yourself out i have something to tell
you though out of everybody i know who
could be a criminal
next to christos stefano you would be
the worst at it
why
you have ocd you have adhd
continue you worry about it this is a
mistake this is an i'm assuming it's not
the traits of a criminal okay
chris
just dumb just real dumb
he'd be the worst at it but you would
not be a good criminal but i'm not but
i'm not going to be a criminal so was it
man you already are my friend i'm not an
open mail that did not know no no no no
it is unidentifiable mail that i want to
return to the right party and i opened
up the same reason i did last time to
find if there was contact information
send it to the judge yeah your honor i
was just trying to return are you going
to turn me in in the zaniest way
possible
say that to the judge
see how you don't judge her go i am i
got like are you going to turn me in
i listen i'm not going to turn you in
but if they come to me i'll throw you
under the bus
but you know what i would love to see a
season of jokers from prison
she's a joker i'm going to get him out
so i double my chances of becoming one
of the jokers
these jokers joker's gonna be me and q
sit in a room soon we get asked to come
to we get asked to come to prisons
huh we get asked to come to prisons
quite often to go to prisons yeah all
right well great did you show the short
play there the marathons play all day
you're gonna be there you and merc could
talk through eight inches of glass
try to pull the pranks off that ain't
gonna be easy i wanna see how this ends
up netting out because i'm gonna do it
i'm gonna do it and i'm gonna see if i
end up in jail or if end up with a great
bit what are you saying right now i'm
gonna write a ransom note to this woman
for her leather pants and i hope that i
hope that i hope that she enjoys life as
well so
let me tell you something do you think i
can really get in trouble can you
imagine because if i put it between the
two of us let me tell you this wait two
of us we both between the two of us we
both were in a podcast that's gonna get
hundreds of thousands of listeners
between the two of us no i'm saying i'm
saying between the two of us not
privately i'm saying between you and i
and our hairstyles
we both drink
i do
listen to me just listen to what i'm
gonna tell you right now we both drink i
drink much more than you do okay okay we
both do drugs
i sometimes do the hard ones this is a
bad idea okay
i should be the guy that you're
convincing this is not a good idea
i'm convincing you so as the degenerate
between the two of us this is not a good
how does this go sour
how does it go south i put i put it in a
bunch of people's mailboxes how does it
go
it's this doesn't it go south discarded
this time almost sent you away
it's discarded it's discarded by anyone
who doesn't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about the person who's
rightfully belongs to is going to take
it and they're going to go
well
i could either report this person to the
belief police or clearly it's it's fun
it's tongue-in-cheek they're writing me
a ransom note for my leather pants and i
will i will oblige and i will write back
to the email and let's play a little
game of cats crime of receiving or
transmitting ransom is but
up to 10 years in prison
listen to yourself pip look up how
illegal it is to open somebody else's
mail i'm just curious no no that's not
what i did though that that either goes
in the trash there's no name on and the
dress is cut off
hold on there's no name it's not illegal
it
is it's not intended for you the law
provides you could not destroy destroy
hide open or embezzle mail that is not
addressed to you what is the punishment
for it
what is the punishment i'm just curious
what's the punishment for it
[Music]
what is the federal law for opening uh
five years in prison
i argue that actually there is not a
name or a clear address on this it still
doesn't matter it's not yours you know
it but then then where does it go
you give it back to the postman but they
they will not it's gonna go in the
garbage it's not the woman's either
never getting her pants or she's getting
them from me in a cutesy way
what's better
let me let me hold on a second i'm just
trying to think of the right one it's
cute babe phrase this
uh okay look what if this woman's like
you know how it's a crime
this is what this is what if i meet the
love of my life it's illegal it's
illegal
it's illegal you know it's illegal right
to not help somebody in trouble whatever
like if you know somebody is actually in
danger so it's like you have a legal
obligation to notify an authority or
whatever it is right i don't know that
yeah it's
yeah i think that's just a seinfeld
thing
no no but look yeah common law in most
states people generally oh have no duty
to okay i'm wrong about that okay well
i'll still use this as an example even
though it's not illegal what you just
said about i'm gonna give it to the
postman and he's gonna throw it away and
she'll never get it or whatever that's
like saying like well i would have
gotten help as the man was being beaten
but he was going to be beaten to death
anyway so what good would the hell no
don't take it don't take your horrific
taste buds arguments and bring them over
here
that doesn't track that doesn't track
the postman very well may know like i
know this address i know the per a lot
of post people know their tenants or not
tenants
clients what does a post person call his
delivery people his his deliveries
i know my route
like he a lot of them they know people
on the route he might know who that is
like the name is not on there i i i saw
it so late i saw it two months late the
sun and rain evaporated the tag
my point is as you go i did all i could
within my power which is to give the
unmarked envelope back to the postman
then she calls
uh
lane bryant or wherever they came from
and says hey i never got my pants and
they say okay we'll send you a new one
hold on let me also say this i didn't
realize it was not male for me so when i
i mean we just opened the pants out of
the plastic bag but when i opened the
original bag i opened it because i
thought it was mine and then i looked
and said what the [ __ ] is this and i
looked at the address and it was faded
out and i looked and it was red pants
and i was like this is the universe
telling me
that i need to take this to the next
level
but or we also under the circumstances
in which i opened it i was not
committing a crime
on camera purposefully go further we all
saw it
no not here in the room no no no no no
no no no no there's three witnesses
package was open because i thought it
was mine but but had you said on camera
i accidentally opened this package
because i thought it was for me and i
made a mistake i'm very sorry i'm gonna
give it to the postman tomorrow there'd
be no issue here you chose to go farther
you chose to go farther and open it more
and more so rose is trying to get you
out of it here we are
here we are
what are you doing
i'm driving
don't you know what you're doing you're
trying to get your friend in trouble
from as soon as you you guys saw it when
you went open that bag i was going sal
don't open it don't open it don't open
it up the package is opened dude the man
the the federal package is the outer
layer not the inner plastic clear bag
wait to see this footage being played in
a courtroom as he's going i it was just
a joke
can we go to exhibit b
the package was open already
then i set a rant
i will cut i will cut up the ransom note
for this woman
and i will make some copies of it and
i'll go and we'll put it in the
mailboxes of the whole block because i
don't know who belongs way to document
this whole thing and then we will wait
we will wait until we get god forbid
though god forbid i get a knock at the
door and it's police though
no [ __ ] [ __ ] that's what i'm trying
to tell you this whole yeah but i think
that i could talk to the cops
yeah you totally could i mean
but the truth is that's that's true
when you when the public sees that you
got let off
because you're a celebrity no no no
that'll go grant's
incorrect no i opened it because i
thought it was mail for me
so and now i'm trying to get the one
back of pants i'm just you're doing it
i'm just doing it in a way that's
indicative of my perspective she's going
to get her pants back
if you give that to the postman and then
she doesn't get her pants in a week and
then she calls the companies she's going
to have them this is from two months ago
that's why the labels failed ain't boden
well free either buddy
they went to i had my other apartments
address and they were sitting out they
were sitting out there in the freaking
rain and sun
look at look look at it
look
it's all faded
those sat out in front of an apartment
on the street in new york for pretty
much in front of a house
in front of a house for two months
nobody took it no passers-by no no
because it wasn't like that like the
door is not on the curb oh i should say
okay i'm sorry all right so like do you
want to like stand down now
but are you going to call off a swat
team on me knock yourself out i'm not
saying [ __ ] what if the lady is
delighted quite frankly i'm an
accomplice now and i don't feel
comfortable yeah you are and if i go
down i'm taking you down with me i swear
to god because you didn't do anything to
stop me
okay
now now i'm gonna say something just now
what if she writes back to the ransom
note and she it's a little tattat and
it's a fun back and forth and
it's it and and then i get a great bit
out of it
dude yeah what are you this is god
giving me material bro what are you
no it's i'm not six are you gonna do
something because you have a funny story
to tell what are we talking about here
no but it's it's there it's primed and
ready to go they're surprised at you how
about this i'm surprised learn how to
write comedy by observing regular life
and not creating wild hair braid
scenarios
to talk about on stage i do enough of
that right
walking down the freezer aisle and going
i've noticed a few things in the ice
cream section too that's all you got to
do to write comedy films i don't think
so when red leather pants come to me for
a when women's pants get delivered to me
erroneously for a second time that's me
being like i need to follow this story
that's what i think okay you you keep
writing about the frozen foods go ahead
i don't write about the frozen foods i
write about like the [ __ ] i was talking
about earlier how the world's in the
toilet
you don't you don't believe in destiny
or fate
what are we children
yeah and we all have guardian angels
what the [ __ ] is wrong with everybody in
this room this is sal's destiny man
that's your death i'm your density
destiny
back to the future by the way that lego
uh the lego delorean comes out april 1st
it's a shame you're going to be in the
big house
i'll bring one to you i'll try to smoke
you one inside of a hoagie world i'm i'm
really surprised how this all went down
if i'm being honest i mean you know
you're very outspoken about it uh
you have such a strong opinion the other
way i thought that you would indulge it
was crazy that i'm looking out for my
friend
and i'm telling you it's not a good idea
do you believe in your heart of hearts
do you believe there is a chance if i
did this that i could get in some form
of trouble
i'm not asking you
i know you just shouted out at me for a
half hour i'm asking them
do you think what do you think on a
scale of one to ten my risk factor is
ten being arrest one being absolutely
jack [ __ ]
oh zero uh
you do you think there's a chance she
can call the cops and the cops come to
my house
i think there's a good chance they might
make you do free ad reads for the state
of new york
because i'm only going to give i'm going
to give a fake email address and so how
they're going to track that down they're
going to really start to now go through
they're going to open it launch an
investigation email address yeah i can't
put my own i'm not gonna make that
mistake twice oh and do you think that
the fbi remember when that phrase was
brought up immediately last time you did
this
fbi three letters you don't ever want
anybody to say to you in anger
you don't think if they got reported to
the higher authorities they couldn't
investigate the email just to figure out
who you are they're gonna allocate this
type of funding into finding this
woman's pleasurable red pants
could you type in my name and i have
your pants and just go to images
i want to show you i want to show you
what i did to this
what i sent this woman
jesus christ
oh my god
i realized after i took it that i was
like oh i don't know if i should really
like looks insane
what is wrong with you
i thought you meant you typed a letter
to her no i i took it took me five hours
i cut those letters out
i thought it'd be funny to put my red
socks on that's where her pants actually
ended
i mean it's very funny looking like the
pictures are really funny i just can't
believe you did this yeah
so this is what i'm saying though
this is a tell this is a televised bit
it's a great project i love this thank
you you're supporting also the postal
like by fine stamps i like this idea
let's do this
you're out voted babe you're out voting
you're in hate country here i don't give
a [ __ ] that i'm not voted you all go to
[ __ ] jail
you're gonna be my first call
[Music]
i'm gonna indict the [ __ ] out of you if
i get called i'm gonna implicate you
left and right the woman you're dating
that you mentioned on an episode of
taste buds
that we recorded today but i don't know
when it airs
i'm gonna i would like to discuss the
how what she thinks of this okay
and i have a feeling
she's not going to agree with you
i have a feeling yeah you got a feeling
black eyed peace yeah i do yeah i do
have you have you run this but i hear
you no no
oh no actually i have actually i have
i don't think she wants me to do it yeah
yeah yeah
cause i brought it home and i was like
look it's a sign
and then she was like no you can't do
that so but she didn't go off on it like
she was gonna get me arrested like you
are well what year was the first you
didn't take it this far in front of her
uh
i feel like it was 2015.
oh okay
yeah i could see getting away with it
back then
why
i don't know i feel like everything's so
crazy now everyone's tight now baby we
live in a world where
somebody says
where if somebody says they were mean to
me at work you almost go to jail i think
i i i know
euphemism for something i think i
benefited though ultimately even though
it was mortifying i benefited from it
ended up being my landlord's girlfriend
because
they're not going to send me she i mean
that was squashed yeah or maybe it can
be a really big and practical joker's
fan and then you'll benefit again
yeah what if it's
yeah
all right well we're gonna do it
and the only thing is the only thing
that was really really if it's not what
if it's somebody who knows the
impractical jokers but wants to exploit
it for all the wrong reasons
all i'm saying is i had blisters on my
fingers
it takes a while to write that thing
for comedic effect i wrote 20 pages
yeah and tell us about the form i have
it downstairs i still have it how many
magazines did you cut out of it was
it had to be 20 15 20. what would be
your tips for like a good ransom note
um
well
i mean there's really nothing to it it's
just that
it's it's you know it's hard finding the
letters believe it or not
for that many pages like it was it was
hard it took it took all night
and uh and actually my hands had
blisters on them from the scissors
because i only had the mini scissors
so like they were all like raw around
the i'm looking for sympathy now
you ain't get it for me all right you
deserved everyone
look here's what happened tonight we
filmed a lot of podcasts today
and this is toward the end of the day we
have fought him and i have fought today
for four hours before we started this
podcast because chris was under the
weather and we came in off the heels of
four hours of fighting and i think
there's remnants in the air of tension
still there's no remnants your idea is
the idea of a stupid [ __ ] and you
shouldn't do it
there's no tension in the air i say it
out of love you're a [ __ ] idiot okay
do this all right i mean that from the
bottom of my heart we're gonna roll the
dice and we're gonna see what happens
rosa was the last time you committed a
crime
what'd you do i think i stole this
chicken sandwich out of the cafeteria
that i didn't pay for okay
you know i don't know you're from philly
i figured you got some good crimes i got
caught stealing when i was in 10th grade
and that kind of scared me straight yeah
i got caught stealing when i was young
too at a baseball card show where my
friend stole and he put all the stuff in
my fanny pack but also like you know and
i got caught
the majority of my meets weed smoking
was done illegally
that's something i've done other drugs
that are not declared legal yet i told
you i used to steal chicken from my my
job and prudential when i finally was in
the actual workforce they had a floor
that was a cafeteria and it was huge and
i had all different options and i used
to go down there and i my friend taught
me this trick it was a hack i used to
get a large dixie cup for fountain soda
and then i just used to shove all the
chicken fingers in them and then i put
the cap on and put the straw in and i
get up to the thing and pay for one
fountain soda but really i had like a
like a pound of chicken in it let me
tell you this
if i got caught that's mortifying but i
did it this is the last thing multiple
times
this is the last thing every day
excuse me
this is the last thing i'll say about
this crime didn't show hot dogs in there
this is
sleepers
when they steal the hot dog cart from
the from the old crotchety hot dog man
because as a joke
and they're running and they can't get
control the cart and it rolls down the
subway stairs and kills the guy that
this is like harmless prank that's going
to go terribly terribly wrong for you
well thank you for just bringing death
into it well i'm just telling you
it's an analogy but this is going to go
terribly terribly well what happens in
this movie i forget
does this do they go to jail they go to
work they go to a they go to a boy's
home and then
one kid gets like where kevin bacon
rapes them over yeah
yeah but the prank goes wrong hits this
guy kills the guy
or or severely injures him i think it
kills him
and uh and they go to jail or not jail
but they go to you know juvie or
whatever it's called
and then when they get out
and they grow up
they run into each other and they find
they they randomly run into kevin bacon
in a restaurant yes and they kill him
and then they go to trial for murder and
they rigged the trial by having a lawyer
they know
work
as the prosecutor against them
who so i remember this came out but
i think one of the kids turns out to be
a prosecutor they have him prosecute
them
and they do this whole average scheme so
they can basically throw the case and
get away with the murder because kevin
bacon was such a bastard to them
what's worse you think do you think it's
worse that i
playfully write to this woman about her
pants in an attempt to really return
them to her or you laughing at
children's being raped
what do you think's worse i wasn't
worried i
what do you think's the worst look what
are we very clear i wasn't laughing at
the kids and sleepers being raped by
kevin bacon
who's laughing at we could play at the
knowledge that you soon will be raped
repeatedly
for committing this crime
ah this has been hey babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey